[Musik]
vom live bei bild mit dem mann den viele
in deutschland für den corona
krisenmanager nummer eins halten der
aber auch die strengsten coroner regeln
auferlegt hat in bayern
ministerpräsident bayerns und csu-chef
herzlich willkommen markus hallo schön
und wir wollen die sendung beginnt mit
einem foto das uns nicht losgelassen hat
weil man den schrei auf diesem foto
gerade zu sehen kann
er stammt aus lesbos ein junge sitzt
dort verzweifelt scheint es auf der
straße nachdem dort das flüchtlingslager
moria abgebrannt ist leben tausende auf
der straße und wissen nicht wohin wenn
sie dieses foto sehen herr söder was
geht mir durch den kopf oder durchs herz
ja wie schon länger dass die zustände
auf lesbos eigentlich unhaltbar sind
europa weist das eigentlich schon länger
dass diese zustände schwierig sind
eigentlich für die europäische union
unwürdig es ist bislang aber viel zu
wenig passiert
das sind glaube ich wird es jetzt
notwendig seien grundlegende
heranzugehen
zum einen einmal wäre es gut wenn wir
wirklich eine europäische lösung
bekommen und zwar nicht nur eine
europäische lösung die dazu führt dass
die mitgliedsstaaten verteilen
ich glaube es war eine coole idee die
eu-kommission selber also das zentrale
europäische organ das vielleicht nutzt
mit einer vielleicht sogar europäischen
einrichtung dort und das eine ist
zweites wir müssen dort die zustände
verbessern durch die ja den aufbau eines
einer neuen einrichtung und dann zum
dritten glaube ich einfach dass man auch
menschen helfen muss insbesondere
kindern die geht es glaube ich auch
kinder und deswegen glaube ich über
deutschland noch mal überlegen und wird
den den anteil den man da hat wohl
nochmal substanziell aufstocken ich
glaube das ist durchaus machbar
das muss jetzt reden sie sagen die
substanziell aufstocken bisher sind wir
bei 100 bis 150 das haben viele als
vorsichtig gesagt jetzt nicht wahnsinnig
großzügig in la genommen von den rund
13.000 die dort in einem
flüchtlingslager in maria gelebt haben
substanziell aufstocken um wieviel heißt
substanziell das muss man reden
ich bin immer dagegen diese täglichen
debatten zu führen 100 mehr tausend mehr
es ist
dort leben natürlich existenziell klar
aber das muss mir immer entscheiden das
war ja letzte woche noch eine große
unsicherheit also war die unsicherheit
was macht jetzt die bundesregierung da
gab es unterschiedliche stimmungen
es gab einzelne länder die wollen viel
nehmen andere weniger ich habe immer vom
freistaat bayern gesagt wenn der bund
sich für eine lösung entscheiden machen
wir mit beteiligen uns natürlich auch
ich glaube einfach dass es für
deutschland machbar ist ohne probleme da
noch einen deutlich höheren anteil an
menschen an jungen kindern und wenn ich
mich aufzunehmen
diese kinder dieser familien auf den
straßen sehen ist es natürlich wichtig
ob substanziell jetzt heißt aus 150 x
175 oder ob sie wie schreibt man
unbedingt substanziellen ein gefühl
dafür bekommen und gerd müller csu
entwicklungsminister sofort eine zahl
genannt der sagt 2000 nehmen wir 2000
können wir aufnehmen um ihr gefühl wir
wollen ja ein gefühl haben und es gibt
fast nichts was gesagt ein gefühl wollen
sie bekommen und für dieses gefühl würde
ich sagen substanziell mehr
aber das muss abgestimmt wenn innerhalb
der bundesregierung das muss abgestimmt
werden mit den europäischen partnern
und das muss auch abgestimmt werden auch
nochmal zwischen einzelnen ländern aber
ich denke wenn der woche noch mal drüber
reden das war in den strom muss das
eigentlich abgestimmt werden mit den
europäischen partnern sie haben schon
gleich wir haben wir haben dieses foto
gesehen haben sie sofort gesagt zwei
sätze weiter waren sie bei der
europäischen lösung an dir in
deutschland fast keiner mehr glaubt
zumindest nicht dass die besonders
schnell kommt nach all den jahren
flüchtlingskrise in denen das nicht
gelungen ist das heißt warum ist man
eigentlich abfahrten bei 13.000 die dort
in dem lager sind einfach zu sagen
menschen verschaffen wir so viel nehmen
ja weil es eine europäische aufgabe ist
und weil es ja um eine grundlegende
frage auch geht das ist eigentlich
sofort zu helfen
kein problem natürlich auch einmalig zu
helfen an der stelle
aber wir wissen durch in europa generell
die frage der migrationspolitik
besprechen und das kann deutschland
nicht alleine
das war ja schon einmal so dass das
deutschland vielleicht versucht hat das
hat erhebliche fraktionen probleme geben
nicht nur bei uns sondern mit vielen
partnern als sie gehören jetzt zum
beispiel auch was in österreich
diskutiert wird in holland diskutieren
oder darauf hinaus muss man ein bisschen
auch klar man muss auch jetzt mal die
zwei drei tage glaube ich glaube ich für
eine gute lösung
also sollte man sich nehmen die dann
auch trägt die auch an der stelle in
moria hilft und dann darüber hinaus auch
ein ein signal setzen macht ganz europa
das heißt es ist nicht das entscheidende
kriterium bei den flüchtlingen aus
moriya jetzt bei diesen rund 13.000 geht
sie wieder hafen was wir schaffen kann
das kriterium ist wie könnte das wirken
das sagt ja auch sebastian kurz nur 1 13
war jetzt nicht so weit auf eher wirkt
das wie damals war ich finde also muss
auch schon muss also differenzieren also
ich würde jetzt nicht nur so es kommt
darauf an wie es wirkt das wäre mir zu
sehr nach stil und haltungsnoten
betracht sondern muss schon sehr
konkrete hilfe
das ist ja auch nur aus meiner sicht die
persönliche christenpflicht in einer
solchen not zu helfen und da muss
deutschland einen substanziellen beitrag
bringen das ist machbar und umsetzbar
das ergibt sich so das große problem was
wir nicht machen können wie wir quasi
wieder ins jahr 2015 zurückkehren und
sagen ohne regeln ohne vorstellung jetzt
machen wir einfach mal ich glaube dass
ich aber auch eigentlich alle einig
darüber dass man das vernünftig machen
muss und das dritte ist ich glaube
einfach dass wir eine europäische lösung
brauchen europäische auch das partner
mitmachen müssen es kann keine frage
dass unser halt machen ja ja das sagen
wir ja jetzt schon ganz ganz lange es
her ist es finden viele wenn sie wenn
sie wenn sie so wenn sie so sehen dann
können sie für 90 prozent von
politischen projekten gleichmann haken
drunter machen wir es nicht machen
versucht will ja jeder haben nur wenn
natürlich bei so einer dramatischen lage
als erster satz ja gar nicht gar nicht
bei weiter nicht nur von ihnen wenn sie
genau zugehört dann war das nicht der
erste sind was vielen was der erste satz
diese woche bei vielen fast eine million
das ist so nach insofern müsste gefühle
jetzt gut zu einem lass uns noch mal
kurz auf das foto gucken dann lasse ich
ihn gezeigt habe denn dass es nur eines
von vielen gesichtern dort auf lesbos
aus moria muss man als politiker wenn
man ja auch eben abwägen muss was ist
die wirkung was sind die konsequenzen
die entscheidung muss man dann manchmal
das herz ausschalten neuen tun würde
ganz im gegenteil deutschland leistet ja
immer schon immer immer wieder noch in
zukunft
einen überragenden anteil grad an dingen
die das herz anderen es gibt ja glaube
ich kein land des so vielen menschen
perspektive geboten hat übrigens der
freistaat bayern kürzen ländern mit der
intensivsten auch finanzstärksten
integrationspolitik also ich glaube da
brauchen wir in deutschland nicht
einen vorwurf machen natürlich kann man
auf der einen seite nie genug tun aber
wird altbundespräsident glaubt marx hat
der wunsch zu helfen im herzen wer es
unendlich aber die möglichkeiten die
dahinterstehende haben irgendwo eine
grenze
und da ist immer glaube ich die balance
an der stelle an echte herausforderung
für jeden einzeln wir wollen noch einmal
herr söder nach moria gehen dort ist
mein kollege til biermann und der hat ja
jetzt schon drei vier tage dort
verbracht im camp und vor dem camp heute
gibt es wieder neue entwicklungen
nachdem es in den vergangenen tagen dort
ja tränengas einsätze gab gegen
diejenigen die die flüchtlinge von den
straßen wieder haben wollten die sich da
belästigt fühlten gleichzeitig auch
gegen flüchtlinge biermann sagt uns ein
bisschen was heute dort in moria und
drumherum passiert es auf lesbos und was
die erwartungen sind von den menschen
die dort auf der straße leben oder jetzt
ins camp zurück müssen wir befinden uns
jetzt war am tag sechs und die circa
13.000 menschen haben sich hier an einer
küstenstraße ein provisorium anlagern
errichtet sie haben hielt ein schild
wald abgeholzt sich daraus hütten gebaut
und der griechische migrationsminister
sagte ja man wolle diese brandstiftung
die griechische regierung geht davon aus
dass das camp durch eine brandstiftung
abgebrannt wurde nicht belohnt indem
darin insofern dass man die menschen
jetzt auch festland schicken würde
sofort das wollen sie ja die griechische
regierung hat ein neues camp am meer auf
einem ehemaligen militärgelände
errichtet 360 stehen da aber kaum jemand
möchte dahin von den leuten sie bleiben
hier an der küstenstraße sie haben angst
das erzählen sie sich hier das ist ein
gefängnis sei dass man da nicht mehr
raus kommen würde dass man das einem die
handys abgenommen werden würden dass man
das einem die gürtel sogar abgenommen
werden würden die griechische regierung
verneint das alles das sind quasi fake
news auch die hier unter den
geflüchteten und migranten kursieren
also das wird nicht angenommen und ich
sitze jetzt hier mit waters ebrahimi 13
jahre alt aus afghanistan er verließ
seine heimat mit seinen eltern seinen
beiden geschwistern und ein paar onkeln
vor fünf jahren
sie fühlten sich von den taliban bedroht
ein onkel soll bei der für die us army
gearbeitet haben und herr söder waters
er möchte ihn gerne persönlich etwas
sagen
die passionierte
also ein video ja eher so dass das war
sehr emotional jetzt und erzählt von dem
jungen haben sie ihm auch noch etwas zu
sagen und wird helfen ob es für den für
den jungen mann der sehr beeindruckenden
auftritt gehabt und auch toll gesprochen
hat ob das jetzt im konkreten fall ist
kann jetzt aber deutsche wird sicher
helfen
und eines ist aber klar auch
griechenland leistet eigentlich viel und
versucht viel zu machen
also wenn sowohl unterstützen das vor
ort die situation besser wird und wir
waren uns eben auch nochmal drüber
unterhalten in der bundesregierung was
wir tun können um die situation zu
schaffen das nicht von markus söder und
dann ganz herzlich mortesa dort
in moria im lager wären heute gehört
dass er zurückgekommen ist ins lager
dort aber natürlich auf keinen fall
leben möchte und der ministerpräsident
der hier sitzt und natürlich nicht
versprechen kann nun in oder jeden
anderen dort sofort nach deutschland zu
hören so holt seine hoffnung war
überhaupt dass sich seine situation
natürlich verbessert in diesem so
schlimmen flüchtlingslager wo sie auch
gesagt haben das weiß man im grunde seit
jahren das tor teilweise mindestens
teilweise im unmenschliche zustände
existieren können sie sich denn
vorstellen dass dieses lager dann in den
nächsten tagen evakuiert wird und dass
zumindest die möglichkeit besteht erst
allen besser zu machen allen ein
besseres wissen kann ich nicht
entscheiden das ist sache der
griechischen regierung das ist sache der
europäischen wenn dann auch der
bundesregierung jetzt könnte ich mich
leichter wenn also ein bayerischer
minister wir sind der freistaat bayern
wird helfen wenn wenn der bund sich
entscheidet dort seinen beitrag zu
erbringen ist doch ganz klar aber die
grundentscheidung müssen wir das
gebrochen hat wenn sie so eine
lebensgeschichte auch an und das dann
hören wie in vivi stark im englisch
diese transportiert wird dort aus lesbos
sprechen sie über sowas mit ihren
kindern
wir haben ja die situation ist ja nicht
das erste mal wieder 2015 eine ganze
reihe von solchen situationen gehabt
auch damals hatte sich der freistaat
bayern einen sehr großen beitrag
gebracht entgegen vieler meinungen und
immer waren
denn es ist ja immer eine frage auch der
palast sie stattfindet aber wir müssen
immer immer schauen was wie wir mit der
situation umgehen welche folgewirkungen
hat es ist das eine
einzelfallentscheidung führt dies zu
einer ganz anderen entwicklungen wie wir
sie hatten die situation von 2015/2016
glaube ich nie hat unser land aus vielen
gründen überfordert
da hat der wunsch zu helfen war das eine
aber es hat schon zu vielen
herausforderungen auch geführt da muss
man das alles klug überlegen gut helfen
aber das ganze im zusammenhang sehen
um jetzt zusammen zu kommen in der
koalition auch die spd der vizekanzler
auch auf länderebene gibt es etliche
stimmen die viel viel mehr menschen dort
aus moriya fordern aufzunehmen wie
kommen sie da zusammen es wird ein
krisen gipfel gefordert wird sie ihm
geben
ich nehme man wäre in der koalition
darüber reden und dann
gemeinsam entscheiden auf einem
krisengipfel möglicherweise bisher geist
glaube ich fordert und herr scholz hat
eine zahl genannt
na ja jedes koalitionsgespräch hat was
mit herausforderungen und krisen zu tun
und da muss man sich halt zu einer
lösung finden aber da wird auch noch
gerungen werden da bin ich ganz sicher
ich habe schon respekt vor der position
von horst seehofer der sagt achtung
einzelfall jahres jeweils doch offenbar
nicht ganz familien und mit kleinen
kindern geht wie vielleicht im konkreten
fall aber man muss das ganze schon auch
mal bis zum ende denken ich glaube es
wichtiger ist eine hilfe zu geben ja
aber es muss alles bedacht werden das
muss dann auch abgewogen werden
das ist nicht so einfach man ich glaube
es ist auch wichtig dass man einfach
eine ein über nacht entscheidung trifft
sondern dass man sie mal klug projekt
gut überlegt der wunsch flicks
abzuhelfen ist da aber muss alle alle
möglichen auswirkungen dann einfach noch
mal bedenken
ich glaube das gehört zu klugen starts
handeln dazu herz und verstand kann man
doch zusammen machen wir haben darüber
gesprochen dass sie sagen die zahl der
war die deutsche lauf nehmen möchte soll
sich substanziell noch erhöhen
nochmal als letztes kurz zu der eu
politik zurück es gab diese
brandkatastrophe auf moorea müssen die
flüchtlinge müssen die menschen dort
einfach begreifen dass so eine
brandkatastrophe nicht ausreicht damit
die eu sich einig damit die eu ihre
politik substanziell ändern
die frage gesetzt nicht zu beantworten
wie sie anzuges tiefer weil ich kann
kann weder jetzt sagen wie die menschen
empfinden das wäre anmaßend ehrlich
gesagt ich finde dass man mal bisschen
anpassen dass wir von deutschland heraus
wissen wollen wie es den menschen geht
was welchen langen weg sieht das ich
haben auch welches leiden da dahinter
steht welche hoffnungen und erwartungen
sind wir haben erlebt auch das noch
vielen menschen die zu uns gekommen sind
ist ganz großartige erfolgsstory es
gegeben hat der integration
das hat auch gegenbeispiele gegeben
deswegen will ich mir das nicht immer an
sozusagen anziehen für andere sprechen
zu wollen
ich glaube nur insgesamt das eines uns
klar sein muss die herausforderung
bleibt und wenn wir auf dauer keine
vernünftige gemeinsame idee finden der
migration der asylpolitik in europa
gestalten und das ja seehofer sehr
bemüht und dran das auch zu schaffen
muss immer anerkennen
dann wird uns diese situation immer
wieder bevorstehen
und dann wird man halt und vermehrt
krisengipfel machen
aber besser wäre es eine vernünftige
dauerhafte lösung tablett von der einen
krise schnell gesprochen zu anderen
krise die sich auch ganz wesentlich bei
ihnen im bundesland abspielt aktuell
unter anderem in garmisch partenkirchen
diese stadt wird plötzlich zum hotspot
dadurch dass man da abends feiern
gegangen ist und vor allen dingen eine
frau die symptome schon hatte und dann
mittlerweile wird sie die
supersprinterin genannt party gemacht
hat und ganz ganz viele menschen
angesteckt hat was halten sie von diesem
fall was halten sie von dieser person
also was geht ihnen da durch den kopf
finden sie das asozial solches verhalten
zunächst muss corona kein lokales
phänomen sondern ein internationales ein
globales und leider auch wieder ein sehr
stark europäisches wenn sich die zahlen
anschauen frankreich spanien österreich
tschechien rekordzahlen und die
krankenhäuser laufen auch wieder voll
besetzt in frankreich gehört insofern
ich fühle mich da leider ich sage das
ganz ausdrücklich das wort leider
betonend bestätigt dass krone eben nicht
vorbei ist der konkrete fall von dem sie
sprechen zeigt wie schnell aus dem
nichts heraus
bei einer nahezu null incidents die
vorher war damals als tourismusort das
glänzend gemacht den ganzen sommer auch
der schulstadt verliebter insgesamt sehr
positiv und dann ist eine person die mit
unvernunft ist und darum sage ich ja
immer wieder
wir müssen die vernünftigen vor den
unvernünftigen schützen es wird also in
dem konkreten fall wird auch sicherlich
mit einem sehr hohen bußgeld überlegt
werden wie man damit umgeht denn das ist
so ein ganz konkret der fall wo leicht
sind und unvernunft andere gefällt soll
das abschreckend wirken jetzt wie man
mit der frau umgehen das gibt die frage
wird mir der vorhang geht die frau
selber hat ja offenkundig das muss jetzt
geklärt von den gesundheitsbehörden vor
ort wie die umstände sind wir haben ja
noch medienberichte im moment einige
bestimmte situation übrigens zeigt sich
dass unser test schaffte jedoch ziemlich
gut ist denn werden haben wir vor ort
teststationen eingerichtet normalerweise
würden leute jetzt nicht getestet werden
wir mal woanders werden denn dann
müssten sie am montag davon arzt warten
hätten jetzt über das wochenende
geradezu teststationen gehen können wenn
sie die fernsehbilder gesehen haben die
vor ort sind das ist die bayerische neue
test strategie da wird also vertragen
ja jedenfalls so schnell dass es wirkt
und wo anders wird es ja gar nicht
gemacht wir sind ich finde es ja immer
so beeindruckend wenn dann gesagt was
machen die bayern alle ist ja und was
könnten sie besser machen
woanders gibt es weder eine zeitachse
der was angegeben wird
es gab praktisch kaum eine
autobahnstation und was vor allem der
große unterschied ist aber dass er ist
werden sie übrigens auch gefragt aber
nicht kurz zu entsagen merkel anderen
bundesländern würde man jetzt auch noch
zahlen dafür für den test wir beten denn
quasi umsonst an
also ich glaube das schafft auch ein
hohes maß an sicherheit und die
sicherheit brauchen wir auch um
möglichst schnell auch lokal reagiert so
könnte das interessant wenn sie sagen
naja andere bundesländer gehen dann noch
niemand eine zeitachse an also das ist
ja das gefühl vieler auch gewesen habe
sich zwar gewundert dass ausgerechnet
die ganzen pannen jetzt in bayern
bekannt wurden aufgeflogen sind aber
viele haben auch gesagt wenn es in
bayern schon so schlecht läuft dann sind
waisen oder als schlecht gelaufen ist
also wenn sie mal angucken wenn wir
haben insgesamt 6000 mit den autos 6000
positive test gehört 6000 haben wir
gefunden
das sind mehr gewesen auf einen zeitraum
von etwas über drei wochen als zwei
monate vor wahlen und haben damit eine
massenhafte ausbreitung verhindert und
es waren überwiegend übrigens auch
tatsächlich urlauber und familien
heimkehren aus anderen teilen europas
kennt und so glaube ich hatte das schon
sehr sehr gewirkt ja da ist manches
ärgerlich weil man es noch besser gern
haben möchte aber unterm strich ist die
strategie hat schon richtig gewesen und
so viel getestet
kostenlos und auch so früh wie kein
anderer und es hilft natürlich auch
trotzdem bleibt corona gefällig den
testen wie sie keine therapie testen
hilft die aber die ausbreitung zu
verhindern und wir sehen gerade in
frankreich beispielsweise spanien
angesprochen
vielleicht auch österreich dass die
sprung der sprunghafte entwicklung
erreicht ist so dass du dann am ende
nichts mehr mal ganze sie das testen ist
deswegen wichtig um aus der schätzung
über eine dunkelziffer in eine valide
größenordnung zu kommen um regional zu
reagieren
wer zu wenig testet schon viele mit zu
wenig testet muss wahrscheinlich mehr
maßnahmen für andere regionen treffen
als wir weil wir dann regional agieren
können dass bayern immer ganz vorne ist
da haben sich ganz viele in deutschland
dran gewöhnen und seine musik so weiter
und so fort
jetzt ist aber bei corona
sie haben immer die höchsten zahlen die
meisten infektionszahlen die wir wissen
todeszahlen warum ist das so
wer hat die meisten infektionen im
moment heute im stark in deutschland
sagen sie es mir ja sie haben es gerade
gehört insgesamt hat barrieren die die
höchsten infektionszahlen nach wie vor
wer ist heute von nrw bei sei kein
problem aber er wird insgesamt im moment
mehr infektion also die recherche muss
man über diesen zeitraum gesamt liegt
bayern nach wie vor deutlich vorne von
allen von allen infektion bislang ein
dann gibt er hatte nrw wieder überholt
ja schon vor ein paar wochen aber kein
problem
das heißt an ihn und her ist dabei
wollten wir wollten wir wollen nur dass
wir dass wir also wenn sie wenn sie das
können wir gar nichts aussagen über
dauer nrw liegt wieder vorne nein ich
auch völlig egal
also sie können erkennen dass von den
steigerungsraten vier länder immer am
stärksten songs
das ist bayern baden-württemberg und
hessen also zunächst mal lax daran am
anfang beginnt mein urlaub also bei
baden württemberg und bayern ganz
einfach sie ist gelernter einen riesen
ansatz gehabt und es waren nicht nur
leute die einmal her gefahren sind so
werden viele tagesausflügler
es war der erste punkt jetzt kann man
sehen dass hat man auch jetzt bei den
ferien gemerkt die betroffenen länder
sind die wirtschaftlich leistungsfähigen
länder haben einen sehr hohen anteil an
familienurlaub an familien heimkehren
aus südosteuropa in nordrhein westfalen
sind aus sogar noch weiter gehende leute
und gastarbeitern alles da und bei uns
hat es sehr stark geben wir sind sehr
nah am kroatien kosovo und sonntag hat
es ihm sehr viele feiern anscheinend
gegeben und familienfeiern und deswegen
in der stadt wie rosenheim
nahezu 80 prozent der infektionen kommen
aus dem umfeld
und wie soll ich mal sagen in keinem
bundesland hatte jeweilige
landesregierung infektion verursacht
alle müssen sich nur darauf einstellen
wie geht man damit um
und wie ist das mit leichtsinn wir haben
jetzt in garmisch gesehen
das ist eine klassische form von
leichtsinn und unvernunft und das führt
leider zu neuen infektionen lassen sie
uns über die schweren auswirkungen auf
die wirtschaft sprechen von corinna
natürlich auch aktuell ganz besonders in
ihrem bundesland ganz besonders auf die
autoindustrie auf die zulieferer
industrie dort aktuell bei continental
die ankündigung dort
unternehmensweit 13.000 jobs zu
streichen 2000 alleine sollen in
regensburg wegfallen und wir haben dort
mit dem betriebsrats-chef mit herbert
brücklmaier gesprochen und er wünscht
sich ganz konkret dieses von ihnen
erinnern welche erwarte dass sich das
land bayern herr söder dass sie sich
stark machen für die verbrenner dass die
noch nicht so schnell ab geschaffen
werden das die noch länger gibt dass man
das ganze eher schleichend umsetzt und
nicht sofort das gleiche erwarte ich
dass sie das weitertragen an den
bundestag und an die eu dass man diese
unterstützungen wenn man die an also
länder wie tschechien rumänien oder
ungarn gibt das dann auch noch nicht
noch auch die arbeit darin abwandert ich
glaube ich der einzige so konsequent
nach also zunächst mal das meine ich
sagen die krise die jetzt gerade in dem
fall da ist die hat ja überhaupt nichts
mit corona in deutschland zu tun sondern
es leider international also wir haben
ja kein locker und verordnet für die
automobilindustrie gilt das für luft und
raumfahrt ähnliche teile maschinen
sondern wir sind ja die ganzen
wegfallende lieferketten die märkte in
europa gewesen und international hohes
also ich bin der festen überzeugung wir
brauchen beim automobilen mehr als man
es tut es ist beeindruckend wie seit
einigen jahren das automobil in
deutschland bekämpft wird von den grünen
ich finde es zum teil bizarren dass man
ausländische investoren in den himmel
hebt ja tesla zum beispiel die
heimischen besten motoren ihr abstrafen
hätte ich nichts anfangen den elena ich
werde natürlich freundlich und ich finde
für einen sensationell was für die
raumfahrt tod also für die raumfahrt
das ist sensationell und auch
beeindruckende persönlichkeit was er
danach aber bei den autos können und so
locker mithalten so deswegen ganz kurz
dazu die unionsfraktion hat ihnen ja
eingeladen zu sich und kurze zeit später
hat dann ein video gipfel mit den
deutschen autobossen stattgefunden so
hätten sie es nicht gemacht den einen
reicht war in beiden fällen in der
einladende
ich habe mich nur stark gemacht dafür
dass wir jetzt zunächst mal wir uns in
arbeitsplätze geben wenn neue der
zukunft ist das prima also da freue ich
mich auch darüber aber über die die
bestehenden die jetzt abgebaut werden
und da ist ganz klar wir wollen
klimaschutz und wohlstand zusammen haben
wir wollen ökologie und arbeitsplätze in
synchronen schalten deswegen auch mehr
werden mehr elektro ja wir haben die
prämie verdoppelt ging auf antrag der
csu
deswegen ist das jetzt praktisch bis
nächstes jahr alles ausverkauft und
werden gleichzeitig die modernsten
verbrennungsmotoren neben diesel die für
co2 perfekte einsatzmöglichkeit mit im
vergleich zu vielen autos die auf der
straße sondern es ist meine feste
überzeugung stadt wieder neue staatliche
fonds zu machen
die sehr bürokratisch sind und ihr biss
sie in sozialistisch wirken immer nach
dem motto zuteilung antragsverfahren
ähnliches mehr
ist die prämie das beste modell es
klappt bei elektro beispielsweise dann
würde es auch bei den modernsten
verbrennen zum beispiel titel klappen
um zu erreichen dass alte co2 schädliche
regen vom sozusagen von der straße
wegkommen und neue drauf also kaufprämie
für verbrenner dem motto ernst daran
halten sie ganz klar für recycling
probleme ist im moment noch ein bisschen
die kanzlerin sagt nein an der stelle
bild kannst dann weiter für die spd ganz
nah dran sind zunächst mal dafür
und da die spd gesagt es ist uns
eigentlich egal und die spd hat damals
in diesem koalitionsgipfel auf sagt auch
was die ig metall sagt sei für sie nicht
relevant
hab mich persönlich gewundert weil ich
so von meiner politischen sozialisation
immer gehört habe naja also was eine
gewerkschaft sagt ist für die spd
zumindest ein punkt jetzt eine kalex hat
sie will auf keinen fall erneut eine
sozusagen ein scheitern haben da habe
ich großen respekt davor
ich glaube nur dass wir in den nächsten
wochen spüren allein an dem tag nach dem
autogipfel zwei tagen einer hat so
scheffler ein großer zulieferer auch ma
in riesigen stellenabbau verkündet
die kurzarbeit ist ganz wichtig und gut
aber sie ersetzt auf dauer nicht die
nachfrage besser leben auch in anderen
branchen bin dann nichts mehr bestellt
wird hilft die kurzarbeit nicht und
darum müssen wir die nachfrage stark und
es geht nur mit einer prämie wenn es
keiner kauft kurz kein steuergeld
wenn allerdings gekauft wird ist es für
beide turniere argumentation oder die
erzeuger haben wir verstanden die frage
ist wie oder ob sie es durch bekommen
einige sagen die kaufprämie nach dem
letzten koalitionsgespräch oder nachdem
nach dem autogipfel am viele gesagt die
die prämie ist mausetot ist sie nicht
ich glaube nicht dass sie tot ist im
übrigen wurde ist auf dem gipfel gar
nicht thematisiert die davon nicht
vergessen so ein gipfel
das sind knapp zwei stunden mit 50
leuten über video
da würde ich sagen da ist gut gesprochen
worden aber das ist jetzt nicht so
gewesen dass man hat und tag verhandelt
hat das muss man an anderer stelle
machen über die haut prämie gar nicht
gesprochen
ich war glaube ich der einzige der es
angesprochen hat muss dazu sein kollege
weilers niedersachsen er ist auch ein
sehr wirklich großartiger kämpfer dafür
wir finden uns ja die auto länder da
schon gemeinsam im interesse wissen sie
was mich was sie halt nicht verstehst
wir sind in dieser technologie weltweit
führend in der welt werden auch nicht
nur elektro wasserkraft ich will mehr
ja wir wollen auch wasserstofffahrzeuge
wir werden morgen in bayern eine große
wasserstoff initiative für nutzfahrzeuge
für lkws vorstellen mit viel fördergeld
ich will synthetische kraftstoffe
fördern
aber ich glaube dass es für eine
übergangszeit so wie der kollege von
konnte das gut formuliert für eine
übergangszeit wie mit den modernsten
brennen verbrennen insbesondere diesel
einen echten beiwerk für klima leisten
können und trotzdem arbeits bezahlen sie
sagen also da scheint ja eigentlich zu
sein in der zulieferer industrie und in
der gesamten autoindustrie
wenn das auf dem autogipfel nur so ein
bisserl am rand martina war wenn sie
damit einen kollegen weil der einzige
waren der es angesprochen wird wann
werden da die nägel mit köpfen gemacht
haben weil ich bin sicher dass der druck
der jetzt durch die entscheidungen der
einzelnen unternehmen kommt dass der
schon was bewegt nicht weit zum beispiel
die woche auch dann überrascht dass herr
hofreiter von dem ich die letzten monate
habe ich gar nichts mehr gehört hatte
jetzt plötzlich gesagt der wa automobil
sei schon nicht unwichtig also wenn sie
mal die haben in den letzten jahren noch
zu beginn als wir die erste prämie
gefordert haben es ja nur für fahrräder
jetzt findet fahrer dadurch fast führen
gern fahrrad heute
dann wäre ich so ist es genau also ich
bin da sehr viel fahrrad zu fördern und
auch die schiene ausbau zu machen
absolut ja nur automobile zu unserem
mobilitäts nix und ich habe mich immer
gewundert wie schlecht wir das auto
retten das sind fehler gemacht worden
das ist auch ganz klar hat aber auch ein
grund warum heute keiner der manager der
bei so einem autogipfel dabei ist noch
einer ist was der generation die jetzt
mit den grünen wenn sie mit dem
hofreiter zusammen die kaufprämie
durchdrücken für verbrenner dann respekt
ja wenn der anderen hoch es mitmacht
dann ist er qualifiziert für diese ganz
gut sie haben gerade schon diese diese
stimmung so in diesen runden
angesprochen und dass dann viele reden
und es sich relativ lange zieht gästen
die eco vorsitzender der spd hat diese
woche gesagt wenn es mal langweilig weil
ich würde in diesem koalitionsrunde da
schreibe ich mir mit dem markus söder
sms stimmt es ja was schreiben sie sich
da so es ist lustig wir müssen es ja
nicht so lustig macht die witze mit
ihnen lästern sie oder in diesen smsen
geht es zum teil weiter dazu als man
vermuten könnte
lästern politiker lässt dann ja mal
moderator arbeitet eng beieinander nein
ganz im ernst in koalitionsrunden sind
manchmal langwierig sei nicht mehr
beeindrucken war eigentlich weiß man was
rauskommt nur ich frage mich warum es
immer so lange dauern muss also in
endlicher endlose auszeiten und etliches
wird gewogen am ende aber ein wenig doch
das ergebnis sondern der kanzlerin oder
werden sonst können sie haben wollen
mir liegt es nicht dass man einmal
sprung wir haben über die autoindustrie
gesprochen wir wollen noch einmal in die
gastronomie gucken auch weil sie so viel
für bayern ausmacht und weil sie
natürlich mindestens genauso stark
betroffen ist von dieser corona krise
und wir wollen sprechen mit einem der
bekanntesten gastronomen hier aus dem
land bayern mit michael käfer der uns
zugeschaltet ist schönen guten abend
herr kefer
das war laut cregan den tod guten abend
herr weise haben wir den toren doch
nicht ganz von der gastronomie droht das
aus im zuge dieser corona krise wie
viele kennen sie schon die
möglicherweise gar nicht mehr
zurückkommt ja also lasst mich bitte
vorweg hören würde ihn und die politik
mal danke schön sagen sie haben diesen
spagat den der den letzten wochen
wirklich sehr sehr gut gemacht und ich
bin echt dankbar dass wir in so einem
land leben können in dem wir leben aber
wir leben in einer wirklich schwierigen
situation und der gastronomie und und
der event gastronomie der auch der
kulturen allen den geht es gar nicht gut
und der hotel- und gaststättenverband
sagt ja dass jetzt kommen die harten
wintermonate dass in diesen monaten soll
mal ein drittel der unternehmen wirklich
von der insolvenz bedroht ist und das
ist ein thema was ich auch ähnlich sehe
weil die sommermonate sind dabei die die
begehrten machen zu und das ist eine
sehr schwierige situation für die
kollegen und wir alle einer meinung nach
also wie kriegen wir jetzt wieder ein
bisschen bisschen mehr leute in die
restaurants rein und vor allen dingen
die gastronomen aus ihrer pleite angst
heraus trotz da ein bisschen mehr mut
aus der politik jetzt braucht mut und
fantasie aus der politik liegt ja auch
ist es ganz wichtig dass es gibt
wirklich hilft das trotz der korona
zahlen die ja leider steigen aber auf
der anderen seite muss man auch sehen
dass sind weniger leute in
krankenhäusern
es gibt weniger leute die die schwere
krankheiten hat bekamen wir uns umgehen
und darum ist es mir so wichtig dass man
aus dieser angst die leute haben weil es
ist sehr sehr viel angst da ist das man
da einen prospekt macht respekt vor dem
virus hat und wenn uns da die politik
mit ideen hilft mit mit ansätzen hilft
und auch mit statements hilft dann
glaube ich ist eine große chance da dass
es doch nicht so vielen kollegen
schlecht gehen wird wie es momentan
aussehen wird die ideen mehr bisschen
mehr mut sagte kefer und dann ging es
den gastronomen jetzt nachdem corona
lack locker und nicht ganz so schlecht
da wird mir wieder die restaurants ein
bisschen voller krieg zunächst machen
wir sehr viel geholfen für
lanzi l nach der freistaat bayern mit
überbrückungs programmen mit von bayern
als einziges 100 prozent abgesicherten
kredit gemacht ein schnelltest 100
jahren genau würde mal sagen wir haben
auch gemeinsam geschafft dann in berlin
durchsetzen die mehrwertsteuer für den
gastronomischen sollten sie auf 7
prozent zu senken
es hilft schon sehr es hat sich in der
gastronomie ganz gut bewährt muss man
sagen auch die regeln werden da gut
eingehalten
deswegen habe jetzt in bayern
entschieden für diese schankwirtschaften
also normale kneipe und der
gastronomischen bedingungen mit sitzen
mit maske bis zum platz speisen e mails
auch zu erweitern
in einer geschichte bin ich ganz sicher
ich glaube nicht dass das corona wie
etwas abgeschwächt ist wir haben ich
habe selbst mit 5 und soviel führen
theologen wie wir in bayern haben ein
gespräch geführt
die sorgen der grund warum im moment
weniger in den krankenhäusern sind
wasserkäfer zurecht anspricht liegt zum
einen daran dass überwiegend junge
infiziert sind und infiziert waren weil
die im urlaub unvorsichtiger waren als
die älteren
das ist aber nur eine frage der zeit ist
werden jetzt auch einige infektionen die
wieder in krankenhäusern alten- und
pflegeheimen entstehen können
da wird man ich hoffe sehr dass nichts
schlimmeres passiert aber in frankreich
sieht man eben das genau dazu fast das
gleiche verhalten das gleiche muster von
dem virus ist und ich glaube nicht dass
es ein französisches corona videos gibt
und ein deutscher ist also das glaube
ich nicht und deswegen wird dieses
übertragen denkbar seien und dann wenn
wir natürlich im winter das problem
bekommen wie wir und das hat er zurecht
angesprochen wie wir die entsprechende
lüftung organisieren können und das ist
das zweite problem im vergleich zum
sommer wenn man außen setzen kann weil
sozusagen die dosis zu übertragen wird
deutlich geringer ist so jedenfalls
sagen uns die auch die klinikchefs und
das kann im herbst noch viel schwieriger
werden also ich kann ehrlich sagen ich
möchte auch keine entwarnung geben
ich befürchte dass wir noch schwierige
zeiten umso wichtiger ist dass wir
rechtzeitig und frühzeitig an anderen
stellen vorsorgen um nicht an zweiten
locker und wieder zu bekommen das ist
nicht als ziel das zu verhindern ist
eine flächendeckende lockerung zu machen
und sie haben recht es ist tatsächlich
so es gibt einfach sehr viele leute
unabhängig davon wie es ist einfach im
moment nicht drin
eine geschlossene gastronomie gehen
werden und das muss man auch dann
umgekehrt ehrlich sagt respektieren noch
mal zu einem käfer haben sie noch eine
idee irgendwas was ihn sofort helfen
würde
söder sagte er will jetzt auch keinen
fall alles auch machen übersetzt mal
kurz mit meinem sitzungen mit meinen
worten aber ganz der faire diskussion
oder die klassischen klubs da also ich
sag mal so wohl nur alkohol ist wo ganz
laute musik ist wo man laut spricht und
singt tanzt das ist einfach sorry das
ist im moment ist tut mir leid weil weil
natürlich verstehe ich dass da sehr
viele existenzen hängen
deswegen versucht mehr
ausgleichsprogramme zu wagen das ist
ebenfalls auf absehbare zeit schwierig
nahezu die sonstige gastronomie ist ist
ja geöffnet jetzt will ich gerade die
leitung ist verschwunden zu einem käfer
wir nehmen aber nochmal mit dass er mehr
ideen und mut fordert und vielleicht
sagt er uns auch in kürze nochmal was
für ihn mir ein ganzes lied ja generell
im leben gut ist immer nur nur während
es soll mut seien aber kein übermut
das ist die entscheidende frage ja auch
nicht zu wenig mut das kritisierte er so
ein bisschen der pr-arbeit grenzen oder
sind wir mal ehrlich sagen sie mir mal
ihr eindruck wo ist in deutschland
strenger oder schlimmer als wollen dass
ich hier ständig von leuten aus
frankreich oder aus spanien oder aus
anderen ländern
dieser mensch in deutschland hat nie
solche einschränkungen kapelle ich habe
so das gefühl wir sind für uns ein
bisschen wie die insel der seligen
wir glauben nicht dass was passieren
kann es ist genau die gleiche
entwicklung wie im märz also ziemlich
genau die gleiche entwicklung ist rückt
näher und wir glauben nicht dass es uns
betreffen kann und da habt ist einfach
meint mein grundphilosophie verstehen
sie
man hört jeden tag dass es gibt 1700
studiokulissen weltweit jeden tag neu es
gibt eine vielzahl an bandbreite von
klugen menschen und wissenschaftlern die
unterschiedliche sagen
man hört dann wahrscheinlich auf den
querschnitt und man muss danach handeln
von dem man überzeugt ist und ich bin
immer überzeugt dass in der hinsicht
eine vorausschauende vorsicht besser als
über mode ist es gibt auch eine
bandbreite ein bundesländern die das
immer unterschiedlich handhaben richter
und eine
ein bundesland mecklenburg vorpommern
zum beispiel hat heute ein fußballspiel
stattgefunden im dfb-pokal hansa rostock
gegen vfb stuttgart waren 7500 leute im
stadion wir wollen einmal hören einen
fan der gesagt hat mensch das ist eine
ziemlich gut gelaufen martin becker
hansa fan ja das spiel ist vorbei es war
ein wunderschöner interessanter pokal
nachmittag mit allem was dazugehört habe
ich habe zum ersten mal wieder seit
sieben monaten gänsehaut bekommen durch
fußballatmosphäre fangesänge für für
gegen den schiedsrichter emotionen all
das was dazugehört war heute zum ersten
mal nach langer zeit wieder zu erleben
das war schön das sicherheitskonzept
ihren rostock war wunderbar die fans
haben sich an alles gehalten was diese
abstände und ich denke es wäre gutes
beispiel auch für andere bundesländer
zum beispiel bayern
sagt zumindest einer sollen bei hansa
rostock der waren hat 7500 ich habe es
gesagt sollen bei hansa rostock
dauerhaft mehr fans sein als beim fc
bayern
naja besser spielen tun sie deswegen
nicht es gab auch in den letzten monaten
übrigens echte echte bedeuten im moment
ist der club nicht abgestiegen ist war
für mich ein sehr bedeutender
emotionaler moment und ein triple also
da weil sie noch mal dass nicht andere
genauso empfunden habe die webseite fans
in bayern schon aber zurück zu dem was
hier fragen wir haben dort in rostock in
mecklenburg vorpommern aufgrund der
tatzeit ich froh wenn er immer kaum
infektion wenig urlauber wenig skifahrer
wenig diese ganzen familien heimkehrer
die in anderen ländern
doch sehr starke rolle gespielt haben
deswegen ist es da natürlich leichter
und verständlicher wir haben uns ja
generell vereinbart infektionsgeschehen
spielt eine rolle
ich würde mal so sagen ich denke wir
müssen uns jetzt in den nächsten tagen
entscheiden ob wir vielleicht so eine
art probebetrieb machen wollen
für den start der bundesliga ein
probebetrieb mit zuschauern allerdings
unter schweren oder was heißt deutlichen
bedingungen der ein bisschen vielleicht
über das hinausgehen masken bis an den
platz personalisierte rückverfolgung nur
die heimfans also keine so was den
anderen augen und es muss dann auch so
nachgehen wie es dasörtliche
infektionsgeschehen wenn es eigentlich
infektionsgeschehen hoch ist dann kann
man das ehrlich gesagt nicht was man
hoch da muss man halt was muss man die
zahl der infizierten
hunderttausende haben also grenzwerte in
deutschland 35 und 50 jeweils das muss
man dann sehen was man macht und das
muss dann aber auch hängt vom jeweiligen
stadion ehrlich gesagt hat dass nicht
alle ist gleichsam ein beispiel fc
bayern
da kann viel organisieren legen sie
haben dort perfekte zufahrtswege bei
anderen muss man sehen ob es dann klappt
und also ich bin zurückhaltend aber ich
sehe eine chance dass wir vielleicht so
eine art probebetrieb machen
für einige wochen dass wir dann bis ende
oktober ein endgültiges bild am und dann
müssen wir einfach sehen wie die
infektionen in deutschland sind also
starten mit dem probebetrieb sein könnte
denkbar sein das müssen wir die nächsten
tage noch mal absprechen unter den
letzten satz was sie wollen ich weiß ich
kann mir vorstellen dass das geht ich
bin also ich könnte auch eine längere
zeit ohne sage ich ausdrücklich weil ich
finde wir haben so viele
herausforderungen schulen
kitas dass das priorität hat also das
hat eindeutig priorität vor dem fußball
stadion aber ich sehe umgekehrt auch die
möglichkeiten die dahinter stehen und
vielleicht ist es auch eine idee wie es
funktionieren kann aber es muss noch mal
bis ins tal geprüft werden
die liga ist kooperationspartners nur
noch wirklich sagen riege hat sich die
letzten monate immer kooperativ
verhalten und deswegen sollte man
überlegen wie man es machen kann wie
viel zuschauer dann ist da pro stadium
sind
das müssen wir noch verhandeln sie habe
jetzt hier schon im gespräch immer
wieder auf die um uns liegenden staaten
verwiesen haben gesagt ja steigen die
zahlen teilweise sprunghaft wieder an
haben dauert sorgenfalten auf der stirn
und eine sehr prominente frau hat diese
woche zum thema corona stellung genommen
iris berben und hat ein bisschen über
corona angst und corona sorgen wird
gesprochen
wir müssen auch in der politik darauf
achten dass keine angst verbreitet wird
wir dürfen nicht in dieser angst
erstarren und wir erfahren ja immer mehr
auch über dieses virus und das sollten
wir umsetzen in die praxis das sollten
wir umsetzen zu sagen wo können wir
eigentlich großzügiger schon wieder sein
wie können wir es handhaben und wie
können wir den größtmöglichen schutz
bieten und damit die leute das trotzdem
das schöne gefühl der kultur haben
das zählt jetzt natürlich nicht ob sie
persönlich gegenüber trage das jetzt
trotzdem einmal auf sie sind sie einer
von denen krone angst machen sozusagen
nein im gegenteil ich habe dafür gesorgt
dass wir gut beschützt wurden bericht
nehmen derzeit iris berben ist eine
großartige künstlerin schauspielen
deswegen zählt ihr wort sehr viel und
sie hat eine ganz besondere beziehung
zum land israel ist einer der großen ja
fast schon botschafter in unserem land
für für die lebensweise von isra wenn
man sich gerade sie dazu in israel am
freitag dauernde runter und drüber das
problem ist so ein bisschen haben wir am
ende das richtige timing und tuning für
alles was wir tun
es gibt verschiedene fälle in der
geschichte wo man eine erste welle gut
überstanden hat spanische grippe zu
schnell reagiert hat zu sorglos war und
die schäden hinterher waren viel viel
größer als beim ersten mal
sebastian kurz den ich sehr schätze mit
dem ich befreundet bin so kameras ist so
kann man das in der politik sagen hat
heute verkündet österreich die zweite
welle sei jetzt da in österreich
man müsse neue maßnahmen treffen und wie
wird man so sagen es geht nicht um angst
es geht nur um vorsicht in der tat kann
man wenn man corona begegnet und
abstandhalten in maßnahmen beachtet den
mund nasenschutz wirklich nimmt das ist
ja eigentlich das absurde in diesen
zeiten an der hoch technisierten welt wo
wir genome entschieden dass es nur die
maske gibt und aber das müssen wir
machen
und wenn es dann irgendeine impfstoff
gibt kann ich nur dafür werben sich
impfen zu lassen ich würde das übrigens
tun und zwar so schnell wie möglich wenn
es also klinisch getestet und in
deutschland zugelassen ist und
tatsächlich diesen schrecken zu nehmen
aber ohne vorsicht und ohne vernunft
also nur nach dem motto ist wirklich
schon hier treffen
das ist kein glück ich will noch schnell
einen mann vorstellen einen der
führenden lungenärzte in deutschland
vize chef der gesellschaft für
pneumologie in deutschland das ist
professor thorsten bauer der ernst
zugeschaltet ist und er sagt mensch
lasst uns ein bisschen mehr infektionen
ruhig zulassen in deutschland im moment
kritisiert aus wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe herr bauer ausdrücklich
nicht die lok dauern der vergangenen
monate aber sagt jetzt mich so ein
bisschen mehr mut würde uns ganz gut tun
und wir können ruhig mehr neuinfektionen
zu lassen warum sagen sie das weise ich
sage das weil wir das instrument hier
eingerichtet haben um den
katastrophenfall zu vermeiden das heißt
wir haben diesen lockdown installiert um
die bilder die in italien und in new
york waren hier nicht sehen zu müssen
das haben wir geschafft jetzt wird
dieses ganze system aber übertragen auf
den infektionsschutz und das ist bei
atemwegs virusinfektionen ausgesprochen
schwierig ich glaube wenn man es
probieren uns hier in eine zwickmühle
die wir nicht notwendigerweise erleben
müssen
herr söder hat gerade gesagt wenn es
einen impfstoff gibt dann würde ich den
auch nehmen
das heißt dass wir aus dieser aktuelle
sachlage rauskommen wenn wir einen
funktionierenden impfstoff haben
und das kann erstens sollte warum und
zweitens kann und wird dieser impfstoff
nicht das tun was ich jetzt alle
vorstellen
also man wird geimpft und das thema ist
vom tisch das ist wesentlich
komplizierter und eine funktionierende
hemmstoff senkt in der wege die schwere
der erkrankung oder minimiert die zwar
derjenigen die sich infizieren können
aber das ist keine alles oder nichts
antwort und deshalb glaube ich dass wir
zwei wege gehen müssen
drei mal den weg den wir jetzt haben mit
lokalen ökologen umgehen müssen ob er
wisse nur weg von dieser magischen zahl
1000 infizierte betrag hin zu einer
sichtweise die dokumentiert dass unsere
krankenhaus krankenhäusern funktionieren
dass wir mit der erkrankung umgehen
können und das wäre zum beispiel der
hospitalisationen sparte kurz bevor sie
antworten so da anschauen wir haben sehr
sehr viele auf die infektionszahlen in
den vergangenen monaten geguckt eine
wichtige zahl ist aktuell natürlich auch
die hospitalisierung strato und da
können wir einmal schauen das heißt die
rate die anzeigt wie viele corona
infizierte noch mit dieser krankheit ins
krankenhaus kommen da war die zahl sehr
sehr hoch ende märz anfang april bei
über 6.000 mittlerweile liegen war da
knapp unter 300 am tag und prophezeit
schauen sie welche ist für sie die
ausschlaggebende ist die nicht
tatsächlich viel wichtiger als die
infektionszahlen noch immer gesagt haben
wir müssen uns davor schützen dass die
krankenhäuser nicht übernutzt jetzt ja
das ist das alte krankenhaus überlasst
ist ein wichtiger faktor keine frage wie
viele andere zahlen auch aber wir haben
ja auch festgestellt und es bestätigen
ja viele ampel also neben der
kompetenten aussage die wir gerade
gehört haben haben wir in bayern auch
uni-professoren hoch wäre logi station
und auch spitzen krankenhäuser die sagen
alle das gleiche
die sagen alle die jetzige krankenhaus
rates sagt nichts aus über das wie es im
herbst und winter werden kann
es geht nicht um den stichtag jetzt im
moment sondern was uns bevorsteht und im
winter ist es wahrscheinlich so dass wir
durch die kombination mehrerer
infektions möglichkeiten
erkältung arkona fiel im innenraum
schlechte lüftungen einfach schlechte
lüftungssysteme die haben unter tatsache
dass es sich nicht nur auf die junge
beschränken muss wenn die zahlen jetzt
so hoch blieben in der infektionsrate
die sich deutlich wider
dann wird es einen übertrag geben und
das haben wir eben woanders auch gesehen
deswegen glaube ich sind wir einfach
klug vorausschauend beraten wenn wir
alles tun die krankenhäuser weiter
stärken den gesundheitsdienst ausbauen
selbstverständlich so dazu eine
ordentliche test strategie zu haben um
möglichst schnell zu erkennen ob jemand
infiziert ist um die weitergabe des
virus zu verhindern und dann gehört
einfach noch mal dazu zu überlegen wie
regional differenziert reagieren nicht
lockern können die meisten bundesländern
ist jack war es bis auf wenige sagen
alles auf sondern wie wir immer schauen
können wo wir an welcher stelle wenn was
passiert schnell entscheiden können
da können übrigens kontakt
beschränkungen dazu in garmisch wir
haben den fall angesprochen gibt es
jetzt wieder kontakte schon nur fünf
personen um zu verhindern dass es weiter
nach stehen das heißt sie sagen auch
wenn herr bauer ganz sauber für sich
argumentiert sie sagen ebenfalls aber
argumentiert wir gehen unseren weg
weiter weil ich befürchte schlimmer
weise evaluieren
es ist nicht so dass jetzt irgendjemand
eine meinung hat jetzt immer gelten muss
reagieren alle miteinander es ist nur
dieses system wechselt ja heute auch im
raum der virologe hendrik strikt sagt
dass heute wir brauchen einen
strategiewechsel in deutschland ich kann
also bei aller wertschätzung das wasser
strikt sagt ist eine schwedische modell
strikt sagt so habe ich ihn verstanden
jeden fall sollte man wenn man wird ja
auch alles verkürzen so in medien
deswegen vielleicht ist das nicht
ausreichend verstanden aber was ich
verstanden aber wir müssen jetzt eine
art durchseuchung probieren und wenn
möglichst viele leute haben dann haben
wir nach den studien die wir haben nach
den zwischenergebnissen sind wir nicht
annähernd von einer solche relevanten
zahl überhaupt bislang in der nähe hinzu
kommen das ist das schwedische modell
liste schwedische modell hat aus unserer
sicht was die todeszahlen betrifft einen
deutlich höheren ansatz gehabt als wir
sie in deutschland hatten auf die
entsprechende einwohnerzahl umgerechnet
deswegen würde ich dieses modell würde
ich nicht ernsthaft also kein guter rat
finden
es ist jeder rat ist wichtig und man
muss ihn auch reflektieren das ist auch
wichtig dass man diskutieren darüber
ich glaube nur dass am ende nicht zu den
ergebnissen für die unser land wirklich
nach vorn ist ja auch so kompliziert wir
haben ganz viele kompetente mediziner
der eine sagt dass der andere sagt dass
und trotzdem ist wahrnehmbar das im
moment zunehmend auch mediziner sagen
mensch ein bisschen mutiger können wir
seien viele leute es gibt genauso wie
haben sie das sehr geschickt
quantifiziert sozusagen immer mehr was
dem eindruck erweckt die mehrzahl der
mediziner denkt so jedenfalls ich habe
in den letzten wochen krankenhäuser
besucht gespräche karten in den großen
klinikchefs in münchen und dann tag und
die bestätigen kurs und sind für mich
zumindest auch genauso praktiker denn
die großen klinikchefs haben schon eine
ahnung wie das weiter ich wollte genau
darauf hinaus wo sie sich die expertise
herholen jetzt gibt es in bayern gerade
eine diskussion
man wollte einmal herausfinden und
prüfen lassen auch vom
verwaltungsgerichtshof wie ist es
eigentlich zu den großen entscheidungen
gekommen unter anderem ausgangssperren
und unter anderem das
gesundheitsministerium zuständig
natürlich hat man gefragt und da waren
für diesen speziellen fall keine akten
vorhanden
das heißt es konnte erst mal nicht
gezeigt worden auf welcher grundlage
diese entscheidung getroffen worden ist
das so und nachbarn entfalten ein
natürlich nicht es gibt ja uns also es
gibt ja kaum ein politiker der so
transparent behandelt wurde wie das
thema corona täglich hat sich
weiterentwickelt
ich selber habe unglaublich viele
pressekonferenzen gemacht wir haben in
einer form die entscheidungsgründe
transparent gemacht wie noch nie zuvor
kaum in der politik muss man sagen und
da gibt es presseerklärungen da gibt s
schreiben da gibt es alles möglich gibt
es da aber es gibt vielleicht nicht den
eine quasi wie man sich das so vorstellt
ein schriftstück ist da wer das sind
unzählige was mich ein bisschen
gewundert hat da wäre so ein komisches
gefühl
die leute wollen irgendwann heraus
klagen und sagen sie klar geht es mal
einfach was natürlich das gute recht
soll jeder machen aber ich glaube wir
haben uns dann bayern
und es ist auch das große gefühl der
menschen übrigens auch in deutschland
ist dass wir unser land unter den
obwaltenden umständen man kann auch
vieles kann man hat man diskutieren
können und keiner war sicher wie es
ausgeht aber wir haben damals eine
wirklich sprunghaft ansteigende
entwicklung eine große erste welle
gebrochen habe sie wirklich gebrochen
das kann man der an der an der grafik
vorhin diese gezeigt habe ich sehr gut
sehen und manchmal wundere ich mich aus
welchen gründen verschiedene leute
versuchen das im nachhinein schlecht zu
reden scheint ein sehr deutsches
phänomen zu sein dass man gerade wenn
man erfolg hat es schlecht redet und
deswegen also will ich sagen das was
gelaufen es war sehr gut
jetzt muss man schauen wie wir uns auf
die zweite herausforderung im herbst und
winter einstellen es hat ganz sicher hat
man erkannt ob wir perfekt in
deutschland vorbereitet sind
weil sie zurecht angesprochen
unterschiedliche regularien aber ich
jedenfalls kann nur für mich als person
sprechen
ich werde nach meiner festen überzeugung
alles dafür tun dass wir nicht wieder
eine situation kommen wo wir morgens
zahlen von vielen toten und auch von
einem sprunghaften anstieg rechnen
ich werde mich jedenfalls engagieren
dass wir unser land weiter beschloss ich
habe es deswegen ansprechen weil das im
moment eine grundlage bietet für viele
verschwörungstheorien auch ja dass die
fehlenden akten aus dem gesundheitswesen
glauben in einer verschwörungstheorie
in der tat aber deswegen mahlzeit ist es
doch ganz wichtig einmal gab keine ist
wahrscheinlich verstärkten wieso
verschwunden ich sage doch das dass sie
haben jetzt gerade von verschwundenen
akten sondern das intoniert das ist gar
nicht nur ein museum sondern gesagt ich
wollte von ihnen wissen ob es ach ja
aber sie haben gerade gesagt
verschwunden nein ich habe vorher gesagt
dass vermeintliche ist ebenso
verschwunden
ich wollte das von ihnen einfach nicht
sehen und einfach dass das der zuschauer
der uns beide ja das will ich auch hin
tausende zahlen millionen zuschauer das
war es der nämlich sich sagt moment der
moderator sagt verschwunden
ihre glaubwürdigkeit ist ja keine ahnung
nein und deswegen wollte ich habe nicht
gesagt dass die akten verschwunden
ich habe gesagt dass das ist um diese
verschwundenen akten möglicherweise
verschwunden ist verschwunden
würde er von ihnen wissen halten sind
oder ob ich sagte meiner welcher vorwurf
verschwunden märkte wo ich möchte
einfach aufklären oder wenn sie sagen
die transparenz die transparenz bei dem
punkt entstehen kann
das problem ist doch im moment dass ganz
viele leute auf ihre aussage zurück
ihren gesagt die verschwundenen akten
und das kann nicht stimmen also dann
ich wollte von ihnen wissen ob das
stimmt ich habe mich schon geäußert aber
er war sprecher immer wieder von
verschleierten es sind keine akten
verschwunden das hat mir wieder von
verschwundenen akten sprechen sie ich
sage ich nehme gerade ich halte gerade
ihr wort fest dass keine akten
verschwunden sind sagen sie aus dem
gesundheitsministerium zu diesem fall da
ging es um ausgangssperren ich wollte
das einfach transparent machen ich finde
dass das ja selbstverständlich finde
dass das unsere aufgabe ist das event
anzusprechen und vor allem nicht
anklagen aus und genau aber wissen sie
was ich mache genau so wie sie mir zu
inhalten auf jedes wort so gehen auch zu
ganz sicher habe ich auf jeden fall also
das ist der ansatz dieses interviews
doch ihr können zu sehr genau ich ja
immer sehr genau zu und zwar auf jedes
wort dann machen wir hier ein strich
drunter unter diese verschwörungstheorie
möglicherweise hat weiß ich hab das nie
verschwörungstheorien sind ja das sind
ja keine verschwörung zum teil sehr
politische argumente bisher völlig in
ordnung dass zu fragen ich werde mich
noch ein bisschen dagegen immer gegen so
aus fragen feststellungen zu machen dass
glaube dass aber dagegen ich mich
während das ja das habe ich das super
dass sie dann sozusagen auf meiner seite
ist aber umgekehrt ist noch mal was mich
an verschwörungs 10 und es wirklich zur
substanz zu kommen die
verschwörungstheorie ist ja das
schwierige dass leute sachen der mit in
verbindung bringen die sowas von absolut
sinn wie sich habe in den 90ern taktik
jährige sehen sie noch kennen
das ist so eine serie wo eben auch
menschen in hybriden oder wenn die leute
gibt und irgendwie geimpft und was weiß
ich alles und ich habe es fast immer
ganz interessante serie
ich hätte mir nie leben vorstellen
können dass leute glauben dass das heute
stattfindet was dafür argumente kommen
wie sie es gibt in deutschland das recht
auch absurdes zu denken und zu glauben
aber ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können
dass er so viele menschen das tun und
dass manche auch so ein stück muss ich
sagen da das eigene radikalität
entwickeln können
da müssen wir uns auch dagegen vor sind
wir haben ja gestern die große demo in
münchen sehr gut gelaufen
sehr kluge umsichtige einsatz der
polizei auch der stadt münchen
deswegen war es jetzt anders als in
berlin hat alles gut geklappt aber
beobachten zumindest genau das zeigt mir
fest haben hierzu gehört herr söder wir
wollen einmal sprung machen nochmal zum
thema csu und kanzlerkandidatur mögliche
kanzlerin sagen immer den besitzer aber
ein thematischer sprung hier aber dürfen
oder von verschwörungstheorien zum
kanzler kann über es gab keinen übergang
aber schnitt kanzlerkandidatur sie
antworten immer wieder zuletzt in der
faz mein platz ist in bayern wie man sie
ist schnell gerade im moment erleben wie
machen sie das eigentlich das ist ja
eine strategische antwort wie ich das
will ich das so deuten darf eine sehr
große politiker antwort mein platz ist
in bayern einfach ist ja auch ein wird's
hier tun ist aber oft nicht so einfach
für ein politiker mit ja und nein zu
antworten
wie machen sie das eigentlich wenn im
freundeskreis gefragt wird oder in der
familie gefragt wird und ihre frau
fragte die kinder fragt kannst du jetzt
eigentlich vorstellen markus nach berlin
zu gehen sagen sie dann auch mein platz
ist in bayern ja also denkst du ist die
lage relativ klar noch nie war ein csu
kanzler zwei der ganz großen strauß und
stoiber haben es probiert es hat aber
nicht geklappt das hat unterschiedliche
gründe
ich glaube dass zunächst einmal einfach
die cdu sowieso das vorschlagsrecht hat
wir haben drei hervorragende bewerber um
den cdu-vorsitz alle drei sagen sie
wollen kanzler werden und und trauen
sich das auch gut zu und insofern ist
allein von der größenordnung zwischen
cdu und csu sie eigentlich völlig
selbstverständlich und klar wissen sie
ich bin in meiner funktion als
parteivorsitzender ministerpräsident der
jüngste den ist jene csu geschichte gab
also die anderen wurden immer entwendet
sie beides wurde strauss stoiber oder
seehofer dass eine später als das andere
und insofern kann sich völlig aus
befördert und der freistaat sehr am
herzen
ich habe auch ein stück dafür gearbeitet
dass ich das die aufgabe bekommen aber
das ist eine wirklich persönliche ehre
diese beiden ämter auch zu erfüllen für
die bayern auch da zu sein und ich habe
ihn nie daran gedacht
dass es überhaupt mal ein thema sein
könnte das darf ich sagen denn ich habe
ja wie sie auch wissen kann man die
achterbahnfahrt auch hinter mir thema
ist nach hinten lagen
natürlich sind schon recht und aber noch
einmal mein platz ist in bayern und wir
waren jetzt erstmal abwarten der cdu
vorsitzender wird und dann waren wir uns
zusammensetzen und vernünftigen
vernünftige weg weggabelung vorbereiten
entscheiden ich glaube man sieht an olaf
scholz
also so früh zu starten ob das immer so
toll ist also die umfragen gehen wieder
zurück für ihn heute in nrw am besten
kann er von der marke werk gerhard
schröder denken was man will aber damals
ja dann sehr späten start gemacht
irgendwann im märz
und wie wir wissen war das damals sehr
erfolgreich ich finde noch eins zeigen
wir haben mit jemandem diese woche über
sie gesprochen der sie glaube ich
ziemlich gut kennt vor allen dingen als
politiker aber über einige jahre aber
was mich wahnsinnig gut er kurz stoiber
der weiß was er will und der setzt es
auch versucht es auch umzusetzen
in den gesprächen immer seine
persönlichkeit natürlich war ein stück
dominanz er wollte immer die menschen
auch erreichen und hat auch deutlich
gemacht er kümmert sich ja weiß gott
welcher mensch hat keine fehler
ich will natürlich mehr über die über
die fähigkeiten reden aber wenn man da
ist
ist manchmal natürlich auch ungeduldige
er will geht hohes tempo in den
politischen prozessen und wartet
natürlich von seinen mitstreitern
absoluten einsatz und das ist sicherlich
manchmal anstrengend geduld ist nicht
die eigenschaften die unbedingt sofort
mit markus wieder verbunden wird sondern
mehr effizienz und durchsetzungsstarken
ich kann nur sagen ist ein
durchsetzungsfähiger kompetenter starker
politiker
die fähigkeiten auch ein anderes amt
auszufüllen
das amt des ministerpräsidenten ist ja
nicht ein weniger als das amt des
kanzlers sondern es ist ein anderes amt
mit eigenen herausforderungen und die
kompetenz
die hat er zweifelsohne aber die frage
ob es überhaupt will und ob die
konstellation der christus ist wie
gesagt eine frage die erstmal
entschieden werden
durch die cdu auf ihrem parteitag sie
können mit der geduld habe ich glaube
ich von ihm gehabt aber so hatte sein
handeln sie sich mit ihm eigentlich über
so eine frage kannst ja wir sind alle im
gespräch mit einem gerät mit allen
dreien fuß sitzen natürlich mit dem
apple und auch mit theorie auch mit
horst seehofer mal wieder
wir reden da immer wieder drüber aber
glaube ich habe alle die ziemlich
endlich auffassung danke markus söder
ministerpräsident bayern csu chef letzte
frage heute läuft werden wir hier
sprechen tennis-finale us open sie sind
selber ganz guter tennisspieler gewesen
sein immer noch bis heute abend herr
weiss nimmt muss immer muss ich mal
schauen
ich wünsche ebenfalls großen erfolg ich
bin ja noch ist der zeit sozialisiert so
ich habe ich habe tennis gelernt als ich
als junger schüler mal zufällig unrecht
hausarrest hatte und sollen auf dem
dachboden waren da war dann alter
schwarz-weiß werden sie energie nur ein
programm damals das war ein spiel
dagegen kann es für die älteren haben
und da habe ich dann das gelernte
regelsatz abhängig tennisverband später
gespielt war im labor des becker dann
natürlich war das große idol und seit
becker war ja nicht mehr so viel an
grenze möglichkeiten und es wäre schon
mal wieder sehr sehr toll vor allem die
us open die sind schon was ganz
besonderes hausarrest für markus söder
lernen wir auch als frühchen oder ich
schon lange wahrscheinlich so unrecht zu
unrecht das könnte auch die szene
abgelöst werden
aber auch das war bei mir und zu bricht
danke markus söder wir geben direkt nach
berlin und dort steht karin amesbauer
und diskutiert jetzt über das was wir
hier gerade gehört haben und verzapft
haben mit dem ministerpräsidenten mit
interessanten und streitbaren gästen
ganz richtig wir haben die letzte stunde
ganz aufmerksam zugehört und wollen
jetzt darüber diskutieren wie sich
markus söder bei ihrem interview
geschlagen hat ob er die richtigen
antworten auf die herausforderungen
dieser zeit hat und ob der kanzler will
und auch kann
dazu bei mir im studio jetzt anna klaus
spiegel korrespondentin in münchen und
söder experte claus strunz journalist
und tv moderator und zugeschaltet
ebenfalls aus münchen patricia riekel
ehemalige chefredakteurin der bunten
herzlich willkommen in die runde danke
dass sie alle da sind und die erste
frage geht an sie frau klaus haben wir
jetzt eben also er hat es ja wieder
wiederholt sein altes mantra mein platz
ist in bayern die frage ist wie lange es
seinen platz im bayern haben wir da
gerade den zukünftigen kanzler oder
zumindest kanzlerkandidaten der union
erlebt
der schatten im wort schatten kanzler
ist in den letzten wochen jahr größer
geworden und nicht unbedingt kleiner
so gesehen war ich schon sehr gespannt
darauf wie er sich jetzt heute
präsentiert in dem gespräch edmund
stoiber hat gesagt
markus söder sei eine sehr dominante
persönlichkeit ich fand auch sein
auftritt sehr selbstbewusst ich hätte
erwartet dass er vielleicht demütiger
ans werk geht in anbetracht der ja doch
schon gewaltigen kroner test pannen in
bayern
aber da war er sehr souverän auch sehr
angriffslustig und sehr staatsmännisch
da hat er auch finde ich boden gut
gemacht da der punkte gesammelt also wir
wissen jetzt akten sind nicht
verschwunden in bayern und selbst die
korona antti korhonen halten sich alle
an die regeln in bayern aber zu beginn
des gesprächs war schon sehr schwach
muss ich sagen gestern hat ja die csu
75-jährigen jubiläums geburtstag
gefeiert und ich finde wir haben heute
nicht den chef der christlich sozialen
union erlebt sondern eher der christlich
scheinheiligen union also seine aussagen
zu jahr und wie viele flüchtlinge jetzt
deutschland aufnehmen soll oder nicht
substanziell mehr was heißt das jetzt
also da hat er schon mehr zum punkt
kommen können wir wollen auf jeden fall
nochmal detailreich darauf eingehen
wasser in den einzelnen bei den
einzelnen themen gesagt hat und auch auf
den menschen
markus söder noch einmal zu sprechen
kommen aber zunächst noch mal an dich
die frage klaus markus söder wäre die
union nicht ein bisschen bekloppt wenn
sie nicht mit ihm ins rennen
wenn man sich jetzt die aktuellen
umfragen auch noch mal anguckt die bild
am sonntag
ergebnis markus söder und also eine
umfrage unter allen deutschen 31 hat
markus söder
31 prozent halten ihn für
kanzlertauglich zum vergleich bei lasche
zins 8 unter den unionsanhängern hebt er
ab wie eine rakete 46 prozent halten ihn
da für kanzlertauglich was glaubst du
also wahrscheinlich ist der beste für
die position des anderen wird es
trotzdem nicht weil die cdu glaube ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass einer der
drei alpha männer in der cdu wieder zur
wahl stehen und einer von ihnen wird ja
cdu vorsitzende das dem dann ein feld
wir nehmen jetzt den csu-vorsitzenden
als kanzlerkandidat das würde mich sehr
überraschen wenn es so kommt wäre es gut
für die union das wäre womöglich sogar
für deutschland ein gutes signal aber
ich glaube es wird eine der verrückten
geschichten seien der beste wird es
nicht sondern es wird der der in der
politik sozusagen die geeignetsten foren
hat und das ist aus meiner sicht armin
laschet der heute einen großen tag hat
das muss man auch mal sagen heute ist
also da kann markus söder noch so gut
gewesen seien politisch gravierend ist
heute das abschneiden der cdu in
nordrhein westfalen in den
kommunalwahlen vola steht nur minimal
verloren hat das ist heutzutage vom sieg
und zusammen mit den grünen die viel
gewonnen haben zeichnet sich da schon
sowas ab und jetzt mache ich einmal beim
stichwort kanzler die gegenprobe mit
welchen dieser männer würden denn die
grünen am ehesten zusammengehen die man
wahrscheinlich braucht wenn man ein
schwarzer kanzler werden will
am wenigsten mit microsoft aber meistens
mit armin laschet hat jetzt habe ich
gestern behielten sich jetzt auch in
seiner staatskanzlei und twitter dass
wir alles begrünt hat soweit ich sehe
den man ja jetzt schon seit 30 jahren
aus der journalistischen nähe und
distanz und wunder mich was aus ihm
gewandes im einen in einer hinsicht hat
er die klare kante verloren und damit
ist aber für die bundespolitik
vermittelbar
und deshalb ist das schon in der
umlaufbahn ich glaube wir haben heute
gesehen dass die solidarisierung der
bundespolitik in vollem gange ist
claus strunz sagt der beste wird es am
ende wahrscheinlich nicht bei der union
riekel riskiert die union das kanzler
und wenn sie mit jemand anderen ins
rennen geht wenn man jetzt auch guckt so
dass der einzige der so zumindest
halbwegs auf augenhöhe mit stolz in den
umfragen mithalten kann
na ja also wir haben heute in markus
söder als entschlossen erlebt und
selbstbewusst und der ist ja auch ein
meister der eigenen inszenierung und ich
kann mir schon vorstellen dass viele
deutsche in den starken mann sehen
nachdem sie doch auch viele szenen aber
er hat es ja selber gesagt der ironische
noch nie ist ein csu-politiker kanzler
geworden und das ist ein problem kann
ein franke auch einen menschen aus hall
stand zum beispiel fast denn ich weiß
dass nicht ich bezweifle das und ich
glaube dass wir machen sicher ein
problem hat und das ist mit jungen
frauen ich habe heute mit seinem körper
hat und ganz genau noch mal angeschaut
und diese körperhaltung ist nicht
unbedingt zugewandt ja lehnt sich zurück
berichten im sessel wenn er nicht auf
seinem hügel aufpasst dann guckte so ein
bisschen zusammen und ironisch und hat
so eine arrogante ausstrahlung also ich
glaube kein problem den jungen frauen
zwischen 20 und 40 und auch wenn er sich
einen grünen mantel umgehängt hat so ist
das doch irgendwie durchschaubaren hund
auf dem arm über bienen umarmt bäume
aber ist er das ich glaube mich ganz ist
er das wirklich wollen wir später noch
mal drüber sprechen aber verwickelt
sieht das problem vor allem bei den
jungen frauen sie frau klaus haben ihn
jetzt auch schon lange sehr nah erlebt
begleiten ihn seit acht jahren ist das
wirklich das problem dass es so ein
bisschen arrogant vielleicht darüber
kommt und damit vielleicht bei der
jugend eben gerade
er - punkte macht er kommt schon immer
sehr breitbeinig um die ecke aber wer in
deutschland wahlen gewinnen will der
muss nicht die 20 bis 40 jährigen jungen
frauen an die wahlurnen bringen sondern
vor allem die wähler ab 60 und alle
umfragen der csu zeigen dass
interessanterweise vor allem die frauen
also eher die älteren nicht die jüngeren
die csu wählen und frau riegel hat ja
gerade ganz zu recht gesagt vielleicht
wird es nicht nur schwer die jungen
frauen anzusprechen sondern auch die
menschen in schleswig holstein
aber ich bin heute mit einem taxifahrer
vom hauptbahnhof ins studio gefahren ein
in berlin geborener junger mann der
gesagt hat also er würde am ehesten
markus söder wählen denn er nächstes
nächstes jahr der union seine stimme
gibt und zwar aus mangel an alternativen
weil die anderen kandidaten allesamt
nicht überzeugen und er zu friedrich
merz obwohl er kluge sachen sagt so der
mann
zudem hat er kein vertrauen und da hat
markus söder wirklich aufgeholt in den
in den letzten jahren das war auch für
mich erstaunlich zu sehen
sie sagen sich begleitet seit acht
jahren und er war immer der mann nehmen
die menschen alles alles zutrauen aber
nicht vertrauen und das hat sich jetzt
wirklich seit der krise wirklich
verändert und ich bin gespannt wohin das
noch führt also markus söder kann
immerhin taxifahrer in berlin schon
beeindrucken die frage ist in schleswig
holstein kann man da eben auch als
franke die menschen mitreißen du kannst
dazu vielleicht was sagen auch als
franke selbst aber auch als jemand der
markus söder schon lange kennt und die
frage noch mal ob er eben durch die
korona krise gestärkt trotz der test
panne gestärkt heraus gegangen ist jetzt
wirklich einer der bekanntesten
gesichter und einer dem offenbar die
deutschen wirklich so in der breiten
mehrheit vertrauen also das kann man
glaube ich auf jeden fall feststellt ist
auch mein leid an maik rosner der
letzten sechs monate für mich war
tatsächlich immer eine konservative
alternative für die bundespolitik
ich bin mit seiner krone politik gar
nicht einverstanden ich finde sie zu
strikt zu streng zu wenig mit augenmaß
zu wenig ausgleichen
zu wenig nach vorne blickend zur selbst
beweihräuchern zu sehr im abgleich mit
anderen wir bayern sind die tollen das
ist für mich kein keine überzeugende
politik aber ich bin der minderheit ich
sehe mit großem mit großen verwunderung
aber auch mit respekt dass die mehrheit
das gut findet und es ist ja für
politiker nichts schlechtes dinge zu
vertreten die die mehrheit der menschen
gut und mehr noch darum geht es ich
glaube aber dass es abseits von kona der
kuki große chance von markus söder ist
unions wählern wieder zu hause gefühlt
zu geben und zwar zum beispiel den fünf
bis zehn prozent
die sich nach rechts abgewandt haben
oder ins nichts abgewandt haben die also
nicht mehr wählen oder die fdp gewählt
haben also sagen wir mal ich sage es
jetzt achtung dem bürgerlichen teil der
afg ich weiß dann gibt es gar nicht bei
den ganzen bösen nazis aber ich sage es
mal andersrum also diejenigen die früher
cdu gewählt haben und jetzt ein oder
zweimal sich die afg zugewandt haben die
könnte er mit seiner breitbeinigen macho
esken junge frauen nicht ansprechen denn
patricia riekel art genau adressieren
und das sind natürlich genau die
zwischen 32 und 37 prozent für die union
darauf muss man als unions strategie
schon mal ein auge werfen
armin laschet beispielsweise glaube ich
würde das nicht gelingen der wird ja er
die politik von angela merkel fortsetzen
der wird er ganz weich mit den grünen
sein
das wird diese klientel viele viele
viele leute die ihre politische heimat
verloren haben in im bereich der
volksparteien
oder glauben verloren haben wieder er
nicht zur union zurück führen also ich
glaube er wäre der kandidat aber ich
bleib dabei die cdu wird auf gas kann
sich einer in der runde vor stellt das
wird im dezember gewählt wird und der
cdu vorsitzende heißt sagen wir mal
armin laschet dass der sich nicht in
spiegel schaut und sagt jetzt werde ich
auch kanzler und das verrückte ist nach
lage der dinge wird es auch aber was
wenn friedrich merz sich durchsetzt dann
schaut den spiegeln ja aber sagt aber
friedrich merz hat nicht nur viele
anhänger sondern auch wahnsinnig viele
gegner innerhalb der eigenen reihen und
sollte sich friedrich merz durchsetzen
dann wurde ich dass er das sehr knapp
tut und dass dann seine gegner in den
eigenen reihen nicht auch noch danach
zum kanzler machen wollen und an wen
wenden die sich dann
dann werden die doch nach bayern pilgern
und bei markus söder ist also ich finde
ich dass ich finde das ist sehr
interessanten gedanken schön das ticket
ins kanzleramt führt über friedrich merz
das interessante ist also auf jeden fall
sind wir uns einig dass er irgendwie
gefragt werden muss und dass der druck
bei der cdu so groß sein muss dass man
das gefühl hat man kann mit dem eigenen
kandidaten keine wahlen gewinnen
deswegen gleich die nächste frage
er ist sehr selbstbewusst aufgetreten
breitbeinig ist jetzt hier paar mal
gefallen aber es ja erst mal in der
politik nicht unbedingt ein manko
sondern kann offenbar kommt ganz gut an
gerade zumindest kann er denken kannst
da was würden sie sagen sie kennen ihnen
eben gut lange begleitet könnte markus
söder dieses amt ausfüllen noch
wichtiger als das was ich sage ist ja
wie gesagt das was der berliner
taxifahrer sagte und mit all den
menschen ich mache mir da immer so
spielt raus und jedem den ich so begegne
und dem man so als als mann oder frau
des volkes bezeichnen würde
frage ich kennen sie markus söder sagen
alle ja ja und das ist schon mal ein
wahnsinniger wert heutzutage fast jeder
kennt ihn fast jeder hat eine meinung zu
ihm
wer ist denn norbert röttgen also wer
außer uns hier in der runde kennt der
norbert röttgen und friedrich merz also
der hat glaube ich in der riege der
jungen frauen von 20 bis 40 noch größere
akzeptanz probleme als markus söder also
ich glaub markus söder hat schon
wirklich wahnsinnig große chance
tatsächlich auch kanzler zu werden im
nächsten jahr und wenn man sich
vorstellt hat irgendwer angela merkel
damals eigentlich das kanzleramt
zugetraut
ja da war noch wahnsinnig viele
fragezeichen in allen köpfen sie war
kohls mädchen die frau aus
ostdeutschland die frau die ganz knapp
nur gegen den schröder gewonnen hat und
hätte da irgendeiner gedacht die sitzt
16 jahre
breitbeinig im sessel hätte auch niemand
gedacht also
frau riekel mal zusammengefasst hier
diese diskussion hat sich auf jeden fall
so danach an dass markus söders große
chance oder seine stärke vor allem die
schwäche der anderen cdu kandidaten ist
was hat er denn was jetzt beispielsweise
armin laschet nicht hat zunächst möchte
ich noch mal sagen hier ist der name
jens spahn ist überhaupt nicht gefallen
und in den umfragen liegt sparen auf
alle fälle von ashan ja und vom ernst
das muss man das auch mal festhalten
aber das was söder auszeichnet vor allen
anderen politikern ist dass er eine sehr
deutliche sprache hat das ist sehr
entschlossen auf das er auch
komplizierte sachverhalte sehr einfach
darstellen kann so dass sie jeder
kapiert und er ist nun denkt in bildern
das darf nicht vergessen in bildern der
frage vielleicht auch als journalist
beim bayerischen rundfunk gelernt ja
also wenn er wenn er aufhört dann so
dass das für die nachwelt festgehalten
wird
ob das jetzt rückkehr des erfolgreichen
fc bayern den champions wo es flughafen
geeilt ist und dann gab es natürlich das
große foto er mit den siegern oder
dieser auftritt mit frau merkel auf
herrenchiemsee ich weiß nicht ob sich
irgendein anderer politiker dieses bogen
wolle diese tollen aufgetaucht hätte
also er weiß das bild macht haben auch
bleiben auch in der erinnerung der
menschen hängen und das zeichnet ihn aus
und es auch sehr sehr geschickt dass ich
höre aus der csu
da mag dass er jede woche sich mit dem
mit den pressesprechern verschiedenen
ministerien betrifft und sich von ihnen
stellen lässt was aus dem hoch anfang
steht und dann entscheidet er auch auf
irgendwo dann auf bild auf ein notwendig
ist dann wohl einen großen effekt
erzielen kann also den zehn jungen da
ist er der absolute weltmeister muss
sagen der bewundere ich ihn und das
gehört auch die modernen business
politik also so gesehen hat er natürlich
chancen als als kanzler
ich denke übrigens auch einfacher wenn
also menschen aus dem milieu wo ich
normalerweise nicht vermutet dass die
politik stark interessieren aber so da
ist es wieder
und das obwohl er das darf man nicht
vergessen
zwei jahren also 20 18
doch der unbeliebtesten
ministerpräsident deutschlands war also
wie hat sich das doch verändert ja der
ist eher wie ein komet aufgestiegen und
die frage ob er chancen hat als kanzler
hängt davon ab ob diese und noch
begleitet also wenn alles eintritt was
er was er in aussicht stellen wird es
gefährlich das worunter dauert noch
lange an
das ist auch dann vorsichtig zu sein
wenn das wenn er das weiter treiben kann
dann hat er chancen wenn allerdings
corona ist sozusagen die menschen keine
angst haben
damit schwinde irgend ein bisschen
komplizierter bilder der meister bate
meistern wir gerade gehört der
selbstinszenierung und in der tat wir
kennen alle die bilder da darf es immer
mal gerne ein bisschen mehr sein bei ihm
der einzige punkt war dann doch immer
sehr bescheiden ist ist mein platz ist
in bayern obwohl er davon ausgehen kann
dass sie im grunde genommen keiner
diesen satz mehr glaubt was steckt da
dahinter klaus naja das kalkül wer sich
zu früh bewegt übrigens interessant wir
haben beide fuhren reflektiert auf einen
moment nämlich sein schröder bezug
also hat in diesem ganzen geschwurbel
warum er doch jetzt nicht schon sagt er
will es werden usw fiel plötzlich an
über schröder zu reden und zwar im
zusammenhang mit dem richtigen moment
schröder sei sehr spät erst im märz des
wahljahres in die bütt gegangen und das
sagt mir doch mein instinkt diesen
zeitplan hat er sich doch schon mal
überlegt vielleicht wenn er mit seiner
frau und seinen kindern spricht dass er
dann sagt ja ich sage meinen platze sind
bei
aber was immer den märz ab also nicht in
friedrich merz den monat märz und dann
sind die sache vielleicht ganz anders
aus übrigens auch weil dann klarheit ist
was mit corona ist und ich würde mal
sagen er ist der absolute abräumer bei
der strategie die die amerikaner don't
waste a crisis nennen also verschwende
als politiker keine krise das ist der
moment wo du da sein muss und da war
markus söder da wie kein anderer war
dass möglicherweise ein freudscher
versprecher dass er da mehr verraten hat
als er eigentlich verraten wollte mit
diesem verweis auf einen der ehemaligen
bundeskanzler der republik ja wir haben
uns sofort angeschaut und gesagt man
muss ja bei diesem satz mein platz in
bayern wirklich auf jede betonung der
kleinsten zill beachten um irgendwas
daraus zu interpretieren und ich habe
allerdings auch gestern hingehört noch
mal bei dieser jubiläumsfeier der csu in
der einzahl stiftung in münchen
da wo dann natürlich auch wieder gefragt
wo ist jetzt ihr platz hat natürlich
gesagt mein platz ist in bayern
er hat aber auch gesagt ach das schönste
an berlin sei doch die autobahn richtung
münchen
und da wirkte er wirklich sehr
authentisch als er diesen satz gesagt
hat und da habe ich dann doch kurz
gedacht vielleicht ist im grunde seines
herzens doch der junge aus der provinz
der sich in der provinz am wohlsten
fühlt aber auch in böse aber er kann
vielleicht sein also vielleicht ist auch
könig von bayern besser als kanzler
kannst du der könig von bayern in dem
aber immer noch vielleicht der kleine
junge aus der provinz steckt wer weiß es
gab einen schönen moment auch auf denen
ich noch mal zu sprechen kommen möchte
söder es kennen was für ein
interessantes gespann wer hätte gedacht
dass die beiden sich heimlich sms
schreiben wenn es ein bisschen länger
dauert mal in verhandlungen hat er mit
einem augenzwinkern gesagt naja lässt
dann kommt fällt erst vor wie
glaubwürdig ist das ja ich glaube man
darf sich politik auch nicht so
vorstellen wie es gern rüberkommt das
sind die einen das sind die anderen die
reden miteinander
natürlich gibt es da austausch und das
ist ja auch richtig und gut so weil am
ende muss es ja jedenfalls in unserem
system immer ein kompromiss geben und
ganz ehrlich wir sagen jetzt schwarz
grün
und schwarz gelb grün und alles mögliche
vielleicht ist ja auch mit der schwarz
rot am ende wie ich erinnern mal dann
kein mensch wollte diese große koalition
also am schluss war sie wieder da also
das alles muss ja jemand der da antreten
will
oder zumindest eine wichtige rolle
spielen will mitdenken ich finde aber
übrigens anders als sie es vorher
intoniert haben sie fanden in der
schwach und scheinheilig in der maria
debatte
ich finde er hat die nachricht des
abends produziert nämlich mit dem satz
substanziell mehr wenig substanziell
mehr mal übersetzen darf es das
vierstellig also dann in deutschland
wahrscheinlich 1000 und 2000 33 sollte
das ja nicht machen
deswegen substanziell mehr
wenn ich überlege was schon aufgerufen
ist was schon angekündigt ist war schon
angeboten ist substanziell mehr richtig
viel mehr er hat sich also ausgesprochen
dafür dass deutschland viele viele
menschen die dort in not geraten sind
aufnimmt das ist schon aus seinem mund
der im zusammenhang mit der
flüchtlingspolitik doch es auch anders
versucht hat einen standort zu finden
sehr sehr sehr bemerkenswert und ich
glaube sogar es ist wenn man davon
absieht dass wenn man die bilder dass
sie die ein nachhelfen ist politisch
auch falsch also ich sehe es bin da eher
bei ist sebastian kurz der sagt
gedanklich man kann nicht jeden
aufnehmen die neben erst mal gar kein
auf weil das muss man alles vor ort
lösen und diesen punkt finde ich muss
eigentlich den hätte ich mir eigentlich
von markus söder viel viel stärker
erwartet denn dann wäre er eine
alternative zu dem was sich im
politischen raum höhere von roth von
links von grün jetzt sagt auch wir
müssen sei dank nehmen warum sagte nicht
mal ein konservativer politiker
wir sind deutschland wir haben ein
technisches hilfswerk wir haben ein
tolles rotes kreuz
wir haben ganz viel spendenbereitschaft
wir haben aktionen wie ein herz für
kinder von einer berühmten deutschen
zeitung wir nehmen ganz viel geld in die
hand und bauen dort den menschen eine
unterkunft dort schnell dann immer
vielleicht nicht die leute vom berliner
flughafen die dann irgendwie 20 jahre
brauchen sondern wir nehmen die die es
können aber vor ort dass der mainstream
jetzt schon wieder ist wir müssen
aufnehmen aufnehmen uns nur noch darum
geht wie viele finde ich fast schon
zynisch zumal ich die frage aufbringen
will
wer entscheidet denn dann wen der junge
war so süß der darf kommen nicht die
gefällt uns nicht so die darf nicht
kommen die muss leider dort bleiben also
das heißt die menschenfreundlichkeit
zieht ihr einen weiteren zynismus nach
sich wen nehmen wir denn dann wer wählt
das aus wie viel also da finde ich
ehrlich von einem konservativen
politiker wenn er noch einer ist nachdem
er so viele bäume um abend und alles
grün macht von einem konservativen
politik eigentlich eher klare kante
erwartet allein und die debatte mal
anzustoßen also klaus wir wissen jetzt
auf jeden fall dir hatte in die antwort
nicht gefallen aber vielen dank dass du
diesen bogen gemacht hast thematisch
weil ich wollte noch mal auf morgen
kommen bei werden jetzt lange über
markus söder über den menschen
gesprochen über seine möglichen kanzler
ambition und die chancen der hat aber er
müsste ja dann im zweifel auch antworten
liefern auf eben diese fragen programme
liefern sagen wo stehe ich was kommt mit
mir
oracle hat ihnen da die antwort gefallen
hat die sie überzeugt oder sagen sie er
hat sich da ein bisschen versteckt also
ich meine substanziell mehr aufnehmen
kann jetzt so oder so deuten so ganz
klar wollte er sich dann nicht äußern
auch auf mehrmalige nachfragen hin
würden sie sagen das war jetzt konkret
genug und er hat schon mehr geliefert
als viele andere oder versteckt er sich
doch wieder hinter so phrasen wie
europäische lösung
also es war ja eine ziemlich harte
konfrontation mit dem süßen kleinen
jungen der das auch so so stark
vorgetragen hat das war schwer für die
markus söder
trotzdem finde ich hätte er mit mir im
reagieren können vor allem weil er mir
ja auch die wähler überzeugen und
natürlich hatte sich hinter allgemeine
phrasen versteckt und das muss in europa
geklärt werden das muss mit den anderen
besprochen werden und mal sehen wie viel
wir aufnehmen es ist glaube ich alles
politisch korrekt gewesen aber
menschlich fand ich es nicht ja da hätte
er der meister der selbstinszenierung
mehr gefühle zeigen können auch mehr
sympathie
eingebracht da fand ich bin ehrlich
gesagt nicht überzeugen und auch wie sie
vorhin gesagt und ich fand es ein
bisschen ein bisschen scheinheilig da
hat eine chance verpasst blüte erstens
nicht auf wenn es um die krone geht ja
da verändert sich auf sein gesicht dafür
ändert sich seine haltung der anderen
plötzlich ganz da aber bei der
flüchtlingsfrage ist noch immer mehr
zurück ins spiel gegangen wie ich jetzt
vor ungefähr und war anfangs ein
bisschen unsicher
politisch korrekt aber wenig menschlich
wenig gefühlvoll sie nicken aber sie
haben ja eingangs schon gesagt da waren
schwach ja ich habe bei dem wort
augenhöhe dass frau riekel gerade gesagt
hat das war genau das das richtige
stichwort also da tut sich markus söder
wirklich schwer und klar über
fernsehkameras augenhöhe herzustellen
ist jetzt noch mal extra schwer aber da
sieht man schon wo sein wo sein manko
ist ich hab ihn letztes jahr nach
äthiopien begleitet da hat er sein
erster staatsbesuch als
ministerpräsident dass ich ein
afrikanisches land ausgesucht äthiopien
da wollte er sein bild vom asyl
hardliner dass er ja bei der großen beim
großen schwestern schreit 2017
da war ja noch derjenige der das
endspiel um die glaubwürdigkeit
ausgerufen hat derjenige der von
touristen gesprochen hat das wollte dann
wieder einfangen letztes jahr und ist
nach äthiopien gereist und da hat er
auch an ein großes flüchtlingslager ganz
im süden von äthiopien besucht mitten in
der wüste
und da habe ich zum ersten mal ein
markus söder erlebt der wirklich
nachdenklich war der ehrlich betroffen
und gerührt schien der auch zum ersten
mal probleme hatte sofort die richtigen
worte zu finden sofort die richtigen
bilder zu produzieren
da fand ich ihn sehr nahbar und
authentisch und hatte das gefühl dass er
überhaupt nicht der hardliner ist den
sie ist so vermissen also ich glaube der
echte der ware markus söder ist viel
weniger rechts und nahe der afg als zum
beispiel horst seehofer
zumal ja zumal ja man muss manchmal
analytisch rangeht hat er versucht
in einer phase von vor zwei drei jahren
die afg zu übertrumpfen im recht seien
sozusagen in der flüchtlingsfrage das
misslungene bis zum unbeliebtesten
präsidenten beliebten politiker
überhaupt jetzt versucht er das gleiche
mit den grünen
also der versucht die afg rechts zu
überholen beim flüchtlingsthema ist
gescheitert jetzt habe ich manchmal das
gefühl durch bäume umarmen versuchte die
grünen links zu überholen
und es wird wieder scheitern also
wahrscheinlich sind sie der
erfolgsformel von markus söder
zusammen mit frau riekel am nahesten
vielleicht muss der nur so sein wie er
wirklich ist also sozusagen der der in
der lage ist zur selbstinszenierung der
die richtigen worte findet und der auch
mal seinem hartz freien lauf lässt und
vielleicht auch mal nicht gleich die
antwort kennt wenn das sich übermittelt
in seiner firma folge sagt breitbeinigen
er dem alten weisen mann zu
berechenbaren art sich vermittelt dann
wäre vielleicht ein ganz neuer
politikertypus der mehrheitsfähig ist
das war grandios ganz schnelle
abschlussrunde wird markus sylla
möglicherweise nächstes jahr ins rennen
gehen für die union
also wenn man markus söder mit merkel
vergleicht dann ist ja markus söder
denninger der so am tischkicker wie wild
an den hebeln dreht und angela merkel
ist diejenige die ruhig auf den auf die
chance zum gezielten schuss wartet und
ich glaube wenn markus söder die geduld
hat den durchhaltewillen darauf zu
warten dass man ihn fragt dann stehen
seine chancen gut um markus söder war
schon immer der unvermeidbare also ich
glaubte und vermeidet so bei dir kennen
wir die antwort du glaubst daran dass
laschet weiterhin für richtig es wäre
gut fürs land dabei wird es nicht
traurige ihre prognose für das nächste
jahr wer geht für die freie union ins
rennen
also markus söder hat das größte ego und
allen politikern und ich glaube dass er
sich als kanzler sie und wenn wir im
nächsten jahr noch bonner riese haben
dann hatte die größten chancen wenn sich
gruner im frühling für stück wieder
schnee dann wird es schwierig der
ungefähr
der unvermeidbare mit dem großen ego da
gibt es möglicherweise einen in münchen
der insgeheim noch ein bisschen darauf
hofft dass die krise nicht ganz so
schnell zu ende es war wie wir gehört
haben
die chancen möglicherweise noch steigen
könnten für ihn
vielen dank in die sehr muntere runde
schönen sonntagabend nach draußen
bleiben sie gesund und bis zur nächsten
woche
[Musik]